this is the thing I'm gonna tell you
just like on Jenny just said if you are
I can listen to another opinion I can
listen to if you feel something
different but if I feel like you're
bucking and you're like going to be
rebellious and you're still making
choices with the same and if I tell you
listen these are red flags you gotta
stop I do this now my father's my best
friend my sister they will tell me
automatically I'm the MTR will tell you
I'm scared of my sister
okay like I'm terrified of her because
she loves me so much she wants the best
for me she's doing so much improving but
I know if she's given me instruction and
I've stepped out
oh I'm gonna get it I'm good she is
going to read me and I'm like terrified
of it but it's a good terrified because
I know she loves you she wants the best
for me and she could see me being if I'm
being hard-headed same thing with my
father